- welcome h3r me I am your leader and
your dad foolish Maximus
I say dad because now I am a dad
speaking of dad I'm here with the mom
who fish your mini minimus minimus poop
emission what's your what's your army
name yeah we are the army marm marm army
dude I have to tell you Dan just hit me
with some smelling salts and I think I
lost the last brain cell that I had
danced back there like with with
smelling salt don't put this on me this
is me in and they're like yo you got to
smell this on my own right and I feel
like I've seriously lost my last brain
so they're like don't worry it's
harmless I'm like okay and now I'm
looking up to like oh yes has an ammonia
in it and if toxic and you've not
supposed to smell it more than once in
your life you get brain damage like it's
literally just ammonia I don't know if
there's anything else Ian how many times
you hitting that bath salt I mean yeah
maybe like once a day not too many are
you serious bro you should not be doing
that
Ian I'm just joking that's the second
time ever really yeah and let it be the
last do you feel a little out of it
because I feel a little out of it when I
did that before you try it too that's
why you try it I was fine okay I was
fine and now my head is swimming I'm
gonna try to get through this bath salts
tile congratulations everybody we had 2
million subscribers oh [ __ ]
Congrats this is incredible somebody
capture the moment on our subreddit as
we hit 2 million I think it was last
night of the night before there you have
it that's the beautiful moment
congratulations everybody we're out here
we're doing it we're providing that
we're getting done
it's been a long journey
and it's been a fun journey it's been a
journey of growth it's been a journey of
embarrassment it's been a journey of
laffs and gaffs and goofs but we've all
shared it together and I thank you all
for this beautiful journey I look
forward to the next million mm-hmm
do you guys have any dedications back
there I'd like to dedicate this victory
to all of the to all of our haters oh
this is for you this is for you guys
do you have haters Ben yeah probably
yeah you don't that's that's funny yeah
since we just brought it up they will
definitely be coming out I like that
dedication to all the haters suck my
[ __ ] dick that's two million
subscribers and guess what the
highlights channel is gonna pass the
main channels and to all of our heads
thank you thank you Dan
suck my dirty stinky hairy [ __ ] chode
and that's right
I wipe back to front there's probably
some [ __ ] on my balls that I'd like to
lick up to while you're down there [ __ ]
gross thank you for that dedication Dan
you're right suck it we've got a lot to
get to today okay first of all Belle
Delphine internet legend at this point
has delivered no we had previously
called for her to add an extra tier on
patreon for her to fart in a jar and
smell it and she went a different route
what she did is she ended up selling her
bathwater which was really clever and
that was after your suggestion I kind of
want to take credit for that at least a
little bit I mean her idea was good yeah
you can take some like I think it was
the inception but but what she did is
she hit me up in the dm's and she said
Ethan I'd like this a new package after
we requested her to fart in a jar for us
and I said holy [ __ ] so we've received a
package from her I haven't opened it yet
and I'm so excited let me tell you she
put a lot of effort this is paper that
she glued on
it's a cat paw and on the front it says
Belle Delphine mystery box it's glued on
and then on the front I don't want to
spoil anything way it showed the bottom
what's on the bottom
oh sure I didn't notice that thank you
her with an egg what's with the egg I
don't want to know what she ate before
she put the part in the jar for you she
does some weird [ __ ] I don't know what
she do but without showing the content
of the box look at this I mean this is
amazing
hello h3h3 I hope you got my little box
and know it's not my dirty socks it's a
little weird must admit but I sent you a
bottle of my own
dot-dot-dot lots of love from Belle
Delphine and then she and she included a
video because I was like if you fart in
a jar it could be anything could be a
stink bomb I need a video of you farting
in the jar so she included a memory
stick and a Mac Kinect there just in
case where you're on Mac amazing amazing
dude this girl delivers hey I think
she's amazing
I'm uh I'm at for life I don't I don't
follow the content but I'm not open this
is what we've got a pink ribbon and a
little box tied I mean there's packing
peanuts in here I am super excited to
open this later because y'all are
getting [ __ ] clickbait day because
we're gonna do it later so don't so you
better stick around for that yeah she
also heard her Instagram feed got banned
I noticed a couple days ago I'm not
really sure last night but we'll talk
about that because we need to rally in
support a belt because she is now a
friend of the show and has a special
place in the heart of these fans of us
they should be army we write our die for
friends of the show and now h3 army has
got your back forever bail
I don't know what's in the jar though
but even this effort yeah
certainly certainly earns a rightful
place in the age of the army but before
that there's so much to get to this one
you know is a good place to start a
friend who doesn't have Twitter sent
this from her flight it's a dude at the
he's in like the fire escape where you
get a little extra room and he's
controlling the mother-loving monitor
with his feet bare feet bare foot and
there's up pictures to prove someone's
like oh what if his arms doesn't work so
she says huh I saw pictures she he was
walking on and off the plane with bare
feet carrying his own bags he just likes
to watch TV with his bare feet okay so
this is what do you do when you see
someone doing this besides recorded them
and put her on Twitter would you say
something I don't know or do you just
give them like a dirty look like yeah
what is good I mean at least a dirty
look excuse me
it's Apple and sugar excuse me you know
sir what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you know that we depressing like that if
you try to say something they'll have
like a really annoying answer they're
ready my feet are clean as your hands
okay sir like they don't listen to
reason at all sir my feet are as clean
as your hands and if you think by
touching this with my feet is making it
dirty it please excuse me I need to hit
some bath salts I mean smelling salts I
didn't know I expect to hit smelling
salts today sir uh what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you how late I thought I was
lazy man you know it's so obnoxious I'm
not that lazy and homey sitting next to
somebody till is that a man or a female
so I thought it was female and then you
said good male no I think I
I don't want to generalize but I feel
like only a female would do this what I
do
disagree I think a man would get his ass
beat if it was a man was doing that I
don't think so this is like woman
spreading this is like a woman spreading
on the airplane well either way curses
upon this person you know it's not that
it's not sanitary it's just [ __ ]
disgust like we we have a society where
the rules can you just be a part of us
like why do you have to yeah
we have unspoken rules okay hands for
some things feed for something exactly
actually feeds for nothing
feet for nothing feet for walking that's
it that's the rule you know
so let's find this person and take them
out know what Dan just yeah take them
out take them out right thank you no
we're not no we're not gonna be doing
any of that H the Army is not actually a
physical we don't we don't take people
out area 51 is in the news
I'm sure you've all probably heard about
this storm
area 51 they can't stop us all this is a
new phenomenon there's a mean page and
they've got a good point you know this
is like democracy in action in a weird
way you've got storm area51 they can't
stop us all Friday September 20th at
3:00 a.m. to 6:00 a.m. I like that
they've got a stop sign stop time
they're like listen guys 6:00 a.m. I
mean let's be reasonable 6:00 a.m. is
like we're all going home by then but
you've got 1.7 million people RSVP going
I'm one of them I'm signed up to let's
go
I think this is a beautiful metaphor if
you have 1.7 million people march on
area 51 what are they gonna do open fire
you know no way they're getting down
there what if they just did though they
just killed them just mowed down a
million people like
how many people do you think will show
up I think a hundred my brother's one of
them we're spending my brother's doing
on Hilde report and he's down there as
he lay in Las Vegas gonna get all
scientific on everyone it's gonna be so
good he's gonna be like the bunking
aliens and all these believers they
wrote in the details we will all meet up
at area 51 alien Center tourist
attraction and coordinate our entry if
we Naruto run we can move faster than
bullets
let's see them aliens and he's got a
really good point
I think if even one percent of those
that are RSVP'd which would be 17,000 I
don't think they're gonna stop 17,000
people unless they straight-up
open fire in which case what do they
think they're gonna see them aliens
isn't it just like desert
well it's underground exactly how
they're gonna get in they gotta get on
the elevator that's true they would end
up just hanging out above-ground very
easy they gotta come out sometime you
know what I mean they can't stay down
there forever
they got AC inside these guys are gonna
be out in the desert and unfortunately
the event does end at 6:00 a.m. so yo I
just found ABC interviewed the guy who
created it yeah and here I just linked
it he looks about exactly like you
expect excellent let's open this up he's
from Bakersfield oh boy you were [ __ ]
Naruto weeaboo yeah what did you wear
that I didn't wear it you would never
wear it oh sorry you just bright you
wouldn't wear it ignorant big difference
I don't know you thought it was cool did
you buy it like cuz you thought it was
dope I thought it was like cool merch
you know it is cool merch you never
tried it on No
I just thought it was cool in your room
did you ever run the rodeo hands back I
didn't know what that run was until
filthy Frank did it in his videos I'm
sure you put that headband on Iran
Naruto all of your neighborhood people
kind of want to know what's in there I
think a lot of people are gonna show up
just because I just cannot be serious
but when people do show up though I'm
working with some great people we're
planning something really cool out there
so I think last time I checked it is
like three million people I just homey
feel like it's no small number there was
one gentleman's got to find this guy I
said I made I thought was just
completely wild he can't run straight
yeah what dude he can't run in a
straight line he does like a little
ninja hop off of a log or something dude
had to stop because he was about to run
off the road his speech game with each
head bro okay Wyatt okay that was trippy
I'm glad we watched that damn my
brother's gotta find an interview that
guy Dan can you bring in the bath salts
it's wearing off we already used all the
rest of them here's where just been
cranking on them back here we need to
explain what it is I don't want people
to think that no it's just anything we
do not bath salts first of all this is a
big difference it's smelling salts you
know when you see someone faint they put
it to you in those and they snap out of
it whatever this is where they're
meeting by the way I put in the address
this is straight from Google man where
they're gonna miss is where they're
meeting area 51 alien Center that's
amazing
so this gift shops gonna be super stoked
we're probably never to open it three em
if they are that day this day they are
they're better oh there's a broth wait
sorry
alien cathouse brothel sorry what
sorry ladies look like that out of this
world their habit are you you don't get
the pretty girls out there at the at
alien paddles that a I looked up like
the the route like the way to get out
there Wow and the logistics are I mean
there's no way even like a thousand
people could get out there yeah that's
what my brother was saying it's like a
small one Road highway because it's a
mill it's like a single lane and it's a
dirt road traffic for a lot of it but I
I truly do believe that is so cool it's
kind of dumb alien cafe there's a bridge
there's a brothel you can go get some
dinner [ __ ] a chick some nasty desert
chick she probably got sand in her China
I like that star would you [ __ ] a desert
chick oh I wonder what's the rate she
takes off her underwear it's just a
bunch of sand but I think it there's
gonna be like a hundred people I don't I
don't think there's gonna be many people
guys although just gonna hang out here I
mean this this store is kind of popping
Gatorade but do you believe this [ __ ] I
mean this is amazing this is what I want
someone just wrote it in a sharpie out
of space outer space vodka you can buy a
shot what world are we living in they
have a bottle and they say you can buy a
shot for ten bucks
oh is this a little shot model okay what
size is it that's not that a nice shot
not where I come from that's a lot of
alcohol
I know these desert people drink area 51
alien Center man it's crazy so that's
exciting I'm very much looking forward
to this September 20th from 3 a.m. to 6
a.m. be there or be square
my brother's gonna be out there
interviewing and seeing what's going on
I hope he doesn't get murdered I'm gonna
tell him to keep a safe distance but I
wanted to interview
people it's it's it's exciting here
there's a little news report about it
too you know they always get it right
you know when the news reports on
something like this they always get it
right
good idea of storming area 51 this yes
you will never explain YouTube as long
as you live you cannot explain what's
happening on YouTube they're trending
page it's such a nightmare as just clip
bait but it appears the US Air Force is
taking these threats seriously national
security correspondent Jennifer Griffin
shows us tonight from the Pentagon it
was a joke but one the Air Force is
taking seriously a Facebook post an
avowed fake designed to get likes
announced a plan to raid the Air Force
Base in Nevada known as area 51 which
has been at the center of UFO and alien
conspiracy theories for decades more
than 1 million people have signed up for
the storm area 51
they can't stop September in which the
post declares we can move faster than
their bullets let's see them alien yeah
you forgot the Naruto run part dumb dumb
no probably some typos yeah if we if we
now if we Narada yeah to spook the Air
Force which doesn't use the term area 51
to describe the 2.9 million acre
live-fire training range the largest in
the United States located at Nellis Air
Force Base in Nevada one of the many
reasons Air Force officials don't want
people to trespass on the base they are
worried some might be killed quote I
want to be surprised some idiots die
yeah but there's gonna be a couple
people that take it too far and they're
gonna die yeah it's probably the aliens
they're trying to protect the secrets
but either way there's gonna be some
dumb thumbs to take it too far I think
they're probably you
two people trying to get lights to
they're really good at just stopping
yeah exactly they got their eyes on the
cathouse alien brothel legally no
military installations or military
training areas is dangerous there has
been renewed interest in UFO sightings
sensitive military has spent 22 million
dollars to research UFOs and announced
new classified guidelines for how its
pilots should report them last month the
Navy briefed several senators on Capitol
Hill about UFO encounters like this one
[Music]
f-18 training mission four years ago off
the east coast of Asia going an
unidentified aerial phenomena you have
objects that are doing things
maneuvering in ways without any obvious
sign of propulsion it's not clear the
1.1 million Facebook followers who said
they're going to storm area 51 are real
and not Russian bots okay that's very
wise me yeah i watch till the end and
then all of a sudden she's hitting me
with why the [ __ ] would Russian Box be
RSVP'ing yes does she think in her mind
if she thinks it's like a real military
invasion the Russian boss RSVP'ing yet
the Russian bots are creating civil war
at area 51 yeah fantastic
that really threw me for a loop thank
you so actually though that got me going
down a rabbit hole I had heard about by
the way do you think there are aliens in
area 51 stupid you think's going on at
area 51 I'm I totally thought that it
was all [ __ ] you know there's
nothing there right well if there was
ever anything there they moved that [ __ ]
long ago right yeah that's been the
rumor since like the 90s right yeah they
got smart by now yeah although maybe Dan
it's a reverse reverse psychology they
moved it and then they brought it back
because everybody's like oh they
probably moved it hide in plain sight it
didn't
Item plain sight baby maybe the people
that work there are [ __ ] aliens bro
and they use that brothel okay whatever
okay yeah are there anyone probably not
I think it's just a military and like
that in general so in general I'm a
non-believer I do not believe that
extraterrestrial life has visited this
earth just because from a physics
standpoint and you know if you ask more
like I all astrophysicists and
physicists that I've heard asked they
always say no because as far as we
understand physics it's just not worth
the effort or really possible for me
what I don't understand is if something
like that happened why would there only
be like conspiracy theories and only
like some weird photoshop's
wouldn't there be like some evidence
that you cannot question right and that
that's something that a lot of the
scientists say too it's like you have
all these first accounts of people who
are apparently abducted by UFOs yet
nobody ever took a photo nobody ever
took a video nowhere no-one ever grabbed
something off the alien ship you know
it's just and it's always some Hicks in
the middle of nowhere who got a finger
in their ass it's like bro you sure you
weren't just at a rest stop like aliens
don't come to Italy yeah exactly
are you sure you were just a little
drunk at a rest stop and got a little
wild with your friend now you're trying
to cover up what was that I only put a
problem I asked yeah right was your
friend Billy you've liked it so no I've
never really believed it and trust me I
would like to believe there's nothing
cooler - I loved x-files it's a it's a
problem with motivation - like if you're
an alien a civilization that's so
advanced that you can do interstellar
travel you can defy what we know as the
laws of physics which is that when you
travel beyond the speed of light it
dilates time so much that by the time
you get here your civilization is
already
moved on thousands of years that's
unfeasible or the other possibility of
great space travel is wormholes where
you travel through the fabric of space
but still as far as we know there's no
way to communicate to them we don't know
how you travel through or go through
wormholes we don't know it seems like a
great improbability and if with an alien
civilization with that great of
technology that is so far beyond us I
just don't understand the scientific
need to come here to observe us why they
we would be so far below them
evolutionarily they didn't make it here
why would they just fly into a little
trick in the air and right do some loop
that he do loop and [ __ ] Hey are you
doing uh like some drone like showing
off his you know if they're that far
ahead of us one we would never detect
them in a million years if they if their
goal was to not be seen we would never
see them I mean we're talking about
these guys are so evolutionarily beyond
us that I mean we're like frickin you
know monkeys plus less the monkeys to
them they probably have AI you know what
I'm saying they've got all like I mean
we're ants to them if they can do that
mm-hmm so I can't see and I can see why
them coming here and studying us would
be of any benefit to them and I can't
see that the resources of Earth would be
any benefit to them because if you're
living in another solar system you have
access to unlimited resources on
comments and other planetary systems way
closer to you and way easier to get then
going through a wormhole and traveling
to earth I mean there's Comet zipping
around space with unlimited amounts of
water and or and minerals and if you're
that advanced you're using solar power
you probably have you probably have a
machinery around
the Sun harnessing power of the Sun
there's no reason to go to that great
length in my opinion the only thing is
like maybe an unmanned drone how do you
can even communicate back mm-hmm
how do you send communication back can
you send it through a wormhole it just
doesn't really even as a thought
experiment it's hard to imagine but then
again I acknowledge the fact that if
they're that far in advanced you can't
really appreciate where their minds are
at anyway that being said I didn't
really believe but man there's some
listening this area 51 should I remember
a couple years ago in the New York Times
the Pentagon released a lot of
interesting information about UFOs and
so we did a little research kind of
following up this story and was really
interesting
back in May it was reported that for the
first time the Pentagon acknowledged
that UFOs are real and military pilots
had seen them a lot but they emphasize
they are not saying they're aliens just
that they don't know what they are for
example here's a video the Pentagon
released of an f-18 tracking a UFO
similar to the one they just showed I
think this is just the full version is
up oh this one is actually a different
one right
yeah there's multiple what they really
[Applause]
so it's like a small cylinder object
it's moving really quickly though it's
like rotating so is this a different
video damn it I guess is a different
incident right yeah from what I
understand when I think that this was
actually originally reported in 2017 and
it's just recently there was like a big
follow up to it where they interviewed a
bunch of these pilots that had seen it
but yeah I guess it's it's a relatively
common occurrence for these you know jet
fighter pilots to see these weird things
that they don't know what they are
doesn't mean they're aliens but they're
seeing something and I mean this is the
video of one of the instances of it
happening so so the Pentagon confirms
the existence of a 22 million-dollar UFO
program although to be all so I mean
that sounds like a lot of money but
twenty two million dollars nothing
government absolutely nothing that's
like a couple of flights one of these
planes cost like three billion dollars
to make but anyway it's really
interesting that they even burnt they
came out and which is so cool in a way
because it it does show some level of
transparency where they're like hey
we're actually acknowledging this we're
doing that yeah I'm sure conspiracy
theorists will be like oh well they're
just doing that to throw you off the
scent whatever I don't know I'd done
either way it's really cool that they
came out and talked about this program
so Dan you have written here many
high-ranking people in the federal
government believe aliens have visited
the planet what is the source for that
that was that was in the New York Times
article I just kind of bullet pointed
the the main takeaways from from their
reporting so when you see high-ranking
people in the federal government we
talking about like military are we
talking about elected officials was I
mean uh military that a lot of people
were speaking under anonymity as they
always do in these kind of things though
I don't think they were singling out
individual generals or anything that
believe it but apparently they're there
there are some within the military that
think aliens are real and so it says it
further says military pilots have
recorded videos of UFOs with
capabilities that seem to outstrip all
non-human aircrafts changing directions
and accelerating in ways no
fighter jet or helicopter has ever
accomplished and they're saying that
article that during like between 2013
and 14 they were seeing it every day
every day mm-hmm where these things
would be out there all day is a quote
from the military guys in that New York
Times all right that's so crazy they
never figured out what it was at least
as as of now at least not publicly so
this is the part of the trips me up the
most it says in a group of buildings in
Las Vegas the government stockpiles
alloys and other materials believed to
be associated with these UFOs that's the
trickiest part and not that's it from
the New York Times to which I mean that
that seems straight out of a movie says
they have as we reported in the papers
some material from these objects that is
being studied so that scientists can
find out what accounts for their amazing
properties this technology of these
objects whatever they are when asked
what the materials were Blum Blumenthal
responded they don't know they're
studying it but it's some kind of
compound they don't recognize this is
just so bizarre yeah and so what they're
saying is they have some kind of alloy
from these UFOs but how how can they not
know what our feel like in this day and
age it must be so simple to know what
metals there are in it or if they're
unknown metals they should I mean are
they saying that there's unknown metals
in it yeah and I mean when I was
researching this this was the part of
the New York Times story that had the
most pushback from the scientific
community because I guess that in
particular to a lot of people was just
like that doesn't make sense we could
definitely figure it yeah unless they're
saying it's unknown but even then I mean
you know ah it's just so cryptic you
know yeah and they don't really specify
how they got a hold it it's like did
they shoot one of these down like how
the hell do you get the yet lit here
right clearly they got some of the
metals so they've recovered so they must
know what it is otherwise how do they
know where it came from
it's all very bizarre but it's to me it
seems more likely that it's like [ __ ]
Chinese drone or some [ __ ] it's possible
you know I mean what other governments
could make something like that China
that's it
pretty funny about it yeah who a Russian
bought I mean it could be the Russians
about those [ __ ] that's seen
their focus on internet more likely i'ma
focus on controlling that that does seem
to be a counter theory is that this
whole thing is [ __ ] and it's all
cover for them kind of subtly letting
some other government know like hey we
know what you're doing you know wink
wink
you know what I meant that I don't buy
because they would just say they're like
yo dude there's what we know you're we
see drones [ __ ] right yeah yeah I don't
know what the advantage of doing it that
way would be so I think I mean guys but
look but like Occam's razor right you
have to consider which two possibilities
is the most likely and it's probably
that one do you think that it's aliens
visiting from another solar system
probably a drone so far advanced that
they can travel beyond the speed of
light yet also still be clumsy enough to
be detected by it humans trapped daily
and being their alloys being recovered
or is it some Chinese spy [ __ ] I mean
come on this Chinese spy [ __ ] isn't way
more likely true yeah I just feel like
if it was alien stuff it just wouldn't
be such a mystery it would it'll be like
obvious in daylight and everyone's like
yeah yeah
and scientists will know and everything
it won't be like a conspiracy yeah
you're just be it's all or nothing they
wouldn't detect it or they would
intentionally be detected yeah I don't
know I just like if I start going down
this whole thing I just feel like too
much like a conspiracy theorist
it's fascinating either way and I as
much as I want it to be aliens are real
and you know there's always these
alarmist who are like Oh aliens are here
too they're day next you know what we
got to take a break right then yeah it's
done I do want to talk more about this
but
take a quick break and we'll continue
the conversation when we come back so
stay tuned everybody you've heard us
talking about honey and the beautiful
magic that it does for you online today
I want to show you in this little
tutorial here there are very special
sole sponsor they're making this extra
episode possible so walk with me through
a honey journey join honey calm / h3 I'm
gonna show you just how easy this is to
join install save money immediately add
to Chrome it's frickin free add to
Chrome bada-bing bada-boom add extension
and guess what you're cooking with fire
and honey yeah okay how easy was that
ela back me up so easy now let's go over
to Amazon okay I'm here let's check out
oh this badass keyboard Corsair let's
check the prices look at this oh my
goodness you can save $17.30 by clicking
this you see there's another merchant
who's selling it for cheaper than the
one that amazon shows you and it doesn't
stop there look here for example here's
another one you know I mean they're
really just endless Jake Paul's I didn't
know he wrote a book it's not loading
come on Jake Paul's buck what the [ __ ]
you really gonna mess this up for me
Jake Paul's book is not loading folks
but let's see you can listen to it what
the hell so where to begin
where'd it begin right when I was in
high school I I hated turning to page 1
all I thought about was we're gonna
write ahead read about your life 18 I
mean how much of a narcissist you have
to be to write a book about your life I
was going to the books were big and the
premise he's complaining you believe
this [ __ ] anyone ever written a funny
textbook I ever in many funny things
inside textbooks but that's not the same
thing Jake I don't think this is a book
you gotta get real Jake well anyway you
can get a great deal on Jake's book oh
no you get the best deal so sometimes
you get the best deal and it wasn't a
hardcover yeah maybe it's the hardcover
you
little discount here but check this out
Jake Paul I got a can we continue the
sample almost couldn't narrate the rest
of this so where do we begin
when I was so anyway I'm gonna keep that
playing TV everybody loves Apple TV
let's see what kind of price we got
there $200 usually save 20 bucks at a
town and I'm telling you it's like this
all over Amazon and okay I'll stop Jake
Falls sorry guys let's try to keep it
spicy and not only does it work on
Amazon it works on tons of huge websites
across the internet I'm talking about
Amazon eBay Game Stop new egg raiser and
so many more and and if you head on over
to Teddy fresh com we've got a 15%
coupon for anyone that has honey
installed let's add here's a shirt that
I'm wearing right now if this is good to
the next weekend let's get an XL because
you know your boys extra large and thick
and voluptuous just this weekend just
this weekend think you'll just add the
pants cuz you know your boy had to do it
to them and let's get the hoodie to
complete the look that's a nice little
haul there you got the pants you got the
pant the hoodie
let's check it out maybe now this one
honey does it's magic it's gonna apply
found a coupon let's see what happens h3
podcast we just saved twenty three
dollars do you see how easy and seamless
it is you can go to Teddy fish right now
get all you want and do a big ass haul
look at this one
saved eleven bucks on the hoodie save
ten bucks on the pants for a total of
doesn't say the max I'll let me crunch
the numbers here guys that's about 20
bucks ok I just crunched the numbers
guys it's that easy go to join honeycomb
slash h3h3
thanking them for supporting us and
making this extra episode possible thank
you guys please for water sponsor god
boss ok back at the show
welcome back Jegs three-nation I just
sniffed five packets of sniffing salt no
I didn't what psychos what did they
doing carrying around sniffing salt I've
never even heard of it but I was saying
Stephen Hawking had this theory because
we were blasting out messages trying to
contact extraterrestrial life and he's
like guys maybe this isn't a good idea
maybe we don't want to be giving away
our position and the galaxy because
these hot these aliens are maybe hostile
they may come harvest our resources I
don't subscribe to that because again
there are so many resources on comets
and other planets throughout the galaxy
I mean why would they need to come to
earth do you know what I mean what's
special about earth other than that
there's life here I don't think there's
anything special about earth other than
that there's life here
maybe maybe our environment is very
habitable and they want to live here
that's the only other thing I could
think of I feel like we could be friends
we could check that's what I'm saying
you don't come all this way to [ __ ] my
[ __ ] up
I don't anyway if there's aliens out
there I think they're dope because I
think to make it that far in the
evolutionary chain you have to be a
little bit team oriented right unless
you're an AI then they'll [ __ ] like then
they'll just take us out
the Borg hello all right let's move it
on shall we
we've got two big stories to get to
we've got that bagel boss you guys have
all heard about the little bagel boss
we've got his whole journey mapped out
and it has an epic journey it's an
odyssey the bagel Odyssey let's talk
about the bagel Odyssey here now this
guy Chris Morgan a very small little man
how tall is he like four nine he's he's
just he's a little dude for sure and
he's starting trouble at all places
bagels
or dude the journey this guy's been on
if you haven't heard about this you're
in for a treat because this guy goes
from getting body slammed at a bagel
store to like signing contracts yeah
he's signing contracts literally in like
three days so join me on this bagel
Odyssey let's let's start from the top
ladies like nobody said that deal here
women in general okay this guy's like an
overgrown in cell yeah he hates women
well let's play okay that really can't
be true
the bagel takedown as predicted it
didn't take much to bring down the bagel
boy but like who's this guy taking him
out that guy is kind of more insane than
the bagel do it himself it was really
not not much of a threat right I feel
like this guy had this one chance to
feel like a badass in his whole life
like me I know I can't win a fight
against anyone but if the bagel dude
wasn't coming to me like I take this
[ __ ] guy out easy you know what I
mean so I feel like for him he had this
one opportunity to be a hero he's
probably a [ __ ] he's like I'm gonna
take this bagel boy out it didn't take
much either
yeah I see why he's got a chip on his
shoulder even some old [ __ ] with a bald
spot can take his ass out but you know I
have some empathy for the bagel boy
because I think being that short it has
got to be tough it is but this
personality doesn't help of course I
mean I used to have a neighbor that was
short like him but it was so sweet and
he was married with kids and like
everyone loved him just of course it's
not like everyone's but in horsey I
understand what you're saying yeah hard
but he's got this paranoid delusional
thing where he thinks everyone's
laughing at him because he's short it's
like bro come on you're like 45 have you
not got over that but I guess he he he
just can't get his he can't [ __ ] you
just can't [ __ ] so imagine he's like 45
and you just can't you know you can't
can't put your dick in anything and that
[ __ ] builds up and then you're being
tackled in a bagel store buy some old
[ __ ] I really don't think that people
are that judgmental I don't hate no I
don't I think women who are looking for
someone to date are yes we also overlook
looks unlike man I agree there's plenty
of women out there
that would get down with the bagel boy
yeah don't questions do you think he's
put his dick in a bagel him yeah what do
you think he's doing with that bagel
extra cream cheese you know so can
actually so there's another video that
continues on after the fight yeah
fantastic I look I love that he bounces
back up in his right back to it so
notice here I want to point something
out to the audience he slams the bagel
down he says [ __ ] all you then he comes
back for the bagel and these he decides
it looks like he cleared out the story
okay play Twitter you really [ __ ] my
[ __ ] up lately man you know probably
popping usually just empty can bagel boy
I cleared it up he goes back he gets the
baby
[Music]
you women that's so scary to have a guy
like that yelling at you as a woman yeah
yeah
so the SOT so the saga starts with
everyone being like you know what the
[ __ ] this little guys losing his mind
at the bagel store and it just keeps
evolving you know TMZ found him on the
street got an interview from him let's
watch that TMZ usually claims so you
sure you won't play that one yeah I was
fun okay it's newsworthy you know what I
mean enough come on you know I just want
to ask you point-blank to your face are
you misogynistic no like just you feel
certain what you feel negatively about
women I won't lie of most of them yeah
because I don't trust any other is that
because of experiences you've had in
your life okay let me just ask are you
homophobic i gage don't bother me I can
hang out with him just don't talk to me
especially the private parts okay bro no
didn't this all start from nobody
you beggar shouldn't be choosers dude if
somebody's looking to touch your dick I
wouldn't say no guy or girl he acts like
I always love this when these homophobes
are acting like gay men are just
fighting to beg for his dick you know
don't flatter yourself bro you should be
so lucky to have a gay man I want to
touch your [ __ ] lastly are would you
consider yourself racist no I have black
friends
okay yeah now if so many Joe upsets me
and he happens to be black or steal
something then yeah I mean that
okay so it's a legend oh my god that
till he just said are you racist he's
like nah but if a black dude pissed me
off I'll call me n-word it's so crazy
man this guy's such a legend he ticks it
all off homophobic racist what was the
other one
he doesn't know what misogynistic yeah
aren't we all what do you mean that's
not a word that his nature did you hate
women so much you really should be
[ __ ] dudes at that point a lot of
these misogynist they have bro up with
their friends and they should talk women
it's like dude can't you see that you
two are in love misogyny is one short
stone throw away from full-blown Pride
Parade dick out gay [ __ ]
reach-around but loving gay let me ask
you what is your ideal woman what is the
type of woman you're actually looking
for you mean looks and everything
however the whole package what is your
ideal woman not honest not just like you
green on it bold somebody that were that
appreciate some ears more say not for
life was he gonna say that let's go back
but I love how he starts with educating
doesn't know what misogyny is
[Laughter]
appreciates a man's money wants to beat
it and love each other
for each other and you're not oh you
know what I mean it shouldn't be based
on the barter system it should be based
on pure love if you attracted someone
you like the company you have good
chemistry you have similar interest yeah
you should want to have intercourse with
a person because you like the person
none of this [ __ ] and I said in the
video stop putting a price tag on
everything that's what everything's
becoming is there any air like anything
you want to clear up right now or yeah
just the same that I've been saying in
all the videos is that stop being
so stuck-up materialistic stop getting
offended if we go oh you're beautiful
you hear our women women men just like I
said this reporter and I'm gonna tell
everybody again if you want to have a
successful relationship women and I
don't mean this in any degrading way men
just wanna eat they want to have cuff
sex make good decent money provide and
and and and and do the hobbies they like
we're not complicated but it seems like
the women and many men have said this
women making it complicated
so you heard out here women we've got
words of advice from the bagel boy it's
not complicated ladies okay we just want
to work make money have sex do our hobby
what the [ __ ] is so complicated I
apologize for this guy yeah and and also
if I tell you you're beautiful don't get
offended I can just imagine him
catcalling like hey hey totes you look
good
hey Dutch you look good let me put my
head up you dress I'm only four nine
four nine you don't have to move I'll
put my head up you just hate I'll get so
offended [ __ ] slap it continues of
course
Inside Edition caught the bagel boy at
the corner everyone's taking turns
this dude Shops at Baby Gap right
where does he buy his clothes no
actually he's not that small I mean that
shirt look at him he looks like [ __ ]
is short but the shirt is like a regular
men's shirt he looks like willow
remember that movie no he could totally
be in willow about little magic dwarves
I love that did he get their tallest
female reporter he could suck her titty
without her even bending down do you
think that a bagel shop is really the
place to take out all of this anger with
all of these strangers pub like innocent
people around why not
let me admit shooting or something that
guy twice my size that women love the
bullies attacking women love use some
old [ __ ] with a bald spot damn this
guy's a total and so when in love the
big guy
dude he's tiny look at him next to her
he's like a magical little dwarf he's
not he's very very very short but he's
getting well dressed his shirts free
fire I mean I don't really have a normal
life is just yeah could I tell ya it's
got it yeah yeah great done talking you
know why I don't really no offense I
don't really like you that much so this
interview is over
it turns out he's posted videos of other
nasty confrontations about his height on
his YouTube channel here he is at a
convenience store I come in here to get
a coffee and this jackass rapist he deaf
I refuse to believe that clerk asked him
what's his height what's your height
this so confused
this poor guy here this is an epic
battle oh they could damn the saga
continues on my friends the bagel boy a
New York Times published an article
learning that the man Chris Morgan lives
in a van and owns owns and runs a
cleaning service home he lives in a van
okay seriously here he is again in the
same outfit like literally how did they
all coordinate this same parking lot
same outfit that's probably where he
lives
it's probably as van right there [ __ ] he
lives there they found out yeah
crazy he lives in a 2008 Chrysler Town
and Country minivan mobile home and in
its parking lot and uses its restroom
Morgan who is divorced told the post he
lost his cool Wednesday while watching
waiting for his breakfast sandwich
because the female workers were giggling
and acting like they were in high school
I [ __ ] like there's no way they were
making fun of his I read that quote by
women being used by women going on dates
they lie they say they like me and then
they use me for my money bro you live in
a well anyway the guy well now he's not
gonna be poor for much longer because
he's made a YouTube page where he is
gonna be raking in the ads yeah that was
my fault yeah oh he's gonna be raking in
the adsense because his channels blowing
up Chris Morgan on YouTube twenty five
hundred subscribers he's well on his way
to stardom and this his trailers at back
alright this is Chris Morgan the real
bagel boss man
check out this [ __ ] Facebook
page fegelein epic trailer Wow
oh hello don't you ever [ __ ] talk to
me like that oh hello
yeah this is his official channel so
let's get on over here and support your
boy here he is berating the he changed
the title Chris bagel boss Morgan goes
to 7-eleven it's called this question
you know in like two weeks
once at 2:00 in the morning and
Farmingdale at a gas station and now
here I come in here to get a coffee and
to get a donut it's May 5th 2019 at
like [ __ ] 5:30 in the morning and
this jackass right here asks me what is
my height this guy's out I come in here
to give I give you guys a lot of
business right a lot of business I just
get whoa hold on a minute I just bring
us to the counter right to pay for my
[ __ ] you don't say hi how you doing the
first thing on the powder is what's my
thought I'm a peon where are you from
what country you from what country are
you from I know I don't know poor guy
this guy's like just don't shoot me
right yeah yeah yeah but the good news
is that he just signed a deal with a
fight promoter Damon Feldman he's gonna
fight other viral stars later this month
so the bagel boy is gonna be getting
paid to to fight other people because
he's a fighter apparently he's a natural
fighter as we saw in the bagel story
boxing all right got great sauce media
shirt on which that is saw that Vegas
story you really aren't ready for a play
whose Anton's watch I want to know as an
old meme right there wait come on what
is this and yeah isn't that the the
you'll know window rate for a guy yeah
exactly
better dating they're like 2011 memes
how did they even get ahold of that guy
here I'll show you though oh the guy who
says uh hide your kids hide hide your
kids hide your wife they've dug deep
into them emails okay I'll show you guys
I'd hide your kids hide your wife
everybody's got it apparently how surely
from Howard Stern is gonna fight him but
surely is like a normal guy I mean
Shirley's gonna kick his ass I was that
possible that he will this is he's
fighting this guy can't you find someone
can you get Joey salads in the ring or
something you know this is gonna be the
least entertaining fight of all time
hide your kids hide your wife because
they raping everybody out here
training what is what is your clown here
see that one to bagel boy oh do you
think they'll talk to you like bagels or
whatnot or the story continues to unfold
as he was invited on stage on Wednesday
night at a hip hop show what the artist
may know am I saying that right hand
okay guys
dude is all right this is the ultimate
humiliation he's lifted up on stage like
a child from the hips all right Nino is
on stage and your boy the bagel boy is
on stage partying I mean he's just a
list celebrity right now think he's
sleeping in his van on this nighter
slammed his hat on the floor he is
loving it god bless man he's really
soaking it up he's doing the Sukkot sign
to everyone in the audience
[Music]
super epic thrown his hat around I
wonder how long this whole thing's gonna
last I think this might be it
I think this highlight here yeah the guy
knows how to party yeah and finally I
thought it would be funny to compare so
the mountain from Game of Thrones Game
of Thrones you guys know he's actually
the strongest man in the world he won
the title so I thought I would show for
comparison opposite problems here's the
mountain and his wife cuz we've looked
previously at Shaq and his girlfriend in
fact let me show pull that up just
before we look at the mountain and his
girlfriend so we've been we've opined
over this picture here about like what
the [ __ ] I mean golly right I mean come
on you don't saying if his dick was even
the size of his thumb she's in trouble
you know what I'm saying so this is one
of my favorite pictures on the Internet
but now we've got something else we've
got the mountain and his wife let's have
a look yellow
oh well we're missing you know black
calm I was joke about black this is
white white did too doggone dude dude
arm is literally the size of her body
seriously I mean licorice
she looks like she's 5 2 and his arm is
the size of her whole body I mean god
bless her she's really look at this
picture
that girl is a warrior man she's my
Sabbath of a Jamba Jain of Steel you
know what I'm saying like golly she's a
cute little thing I mean she's a really
cute
little sweet looking thing and there's
no way there is no [ __ ] way it looks
like a giant you know well he is
enormous
yeah you better say if there were a
giant yeah I was wonder if like if in
the future a future civilization or
aliens dig up our remains like if you
find someone like Shaq and someone like
the bagel boy are they going to even
realize that it's the same species are
they going to be like oh this is there's
like a whole race of little people and
Giants it's hard to believe that we're
the same species but there's there's no
way I mean how can they physically have
sex this is why did a dot-com I just
looked it up he according to google he
weighs 425 pounds wow she looks like she
weighs 80 right yeah so I guess she's
just she must be into it right he's only
I say only it's still tallest bug but
he's 69 which what that's huge what do
you mean only there's a lot of
basketball players at 6:09 there are
many people smaller than that is not
just like massive like for sure I don't
think there's many basketball players
that are taller than 6 9 yeah not many
no like there's some that are like 7 and
they're just [ __ ] freaks of nature
they can barely move because they're so
tall yet they're just like ooh like 4 :
Shaq is 7 1 yeah and he's like again
right freakishly tall yeah my theories
the checks not even a good basketball
player he's just tall and heavy he just
lifts his hand up I remember watching
Shaq play for the Lakers he literally
will just drop it in the net it's like
cool so much you know I'm sure he's good
he's yeah I'm sure he's he's an amazing
athlete but I can't get over this man I
can't get over this her vagina must be
like decide the heard the opening must
be the size of her head alright I'll
stop but it's fast man you have like I
mean she's proud
so worn out by having sex with them
regularly that it's just like enormous
but it's all you can think about right
am I'm not crazy
no it definitely yeah it's obviously
like what the how do you guys [ __ ] doing
anything
I mean his index Peters the size of my
penis
his little pinky fingers the size my
penis on a good day [ __ ] how look at
the waist looking at her all right I
gotta get this off the screen crazy huh
and finally we've got there's so much to
get - mm-hmm this document is like well
just have to come back on Tuesday and
tackle all these issues because we're
already running how long we going like
our hour 10 ish okay let's do let's do
the box okay well this is insane so
Belle Delphine sent us the box after
everything we've been through we talked
about her patreon we talked about her we
watched her videos and I have to say
that I was immediately impressed with
her I immediately became a fan of hers
because she's funny I mean she's she's
very self-aware
she's very truly and these these stinky
little uh horny little virgins
I don't know if they're virgins
necessarily but there's definitely
stinky are paying out that ass to get
her premium pics and to just play along
and this whole role-playing thing that
she's this world she's built yeah where
I'm sure she's making a lot of money and
so I had suggested originally that she
fart in a jar she has all these tier
lists on patreon up to $2,500 which is
god-tier which I'm sure there are
several dudes subscribed to that area so
I suggested adding a tier above God
called the fart tier in which she would
fart in a mason jar bottle it and then
send it to you and shortly after we made
that suggestion she came out with the
bathwater thing which everybody's heard
about she started selling her there
used bathwater I've heard about it all
over the news it's been an even on
Howard Stern I heard him talking about
it it's like man she is gone
international and she deserves it I I
really I give her all the respect Nora I
think she's great I really do think
she's great so she started bottling her
bathwater her used bathwater and selling
it for 30 pounds of pop which is
fantastic she did she cleaned up but it
was a great little package said she sold
out I don't know how you sell out a
bathwater he just turned on the tap you
get my bathwater he's that simple but
around the same time she hit me up in
the DMS and she said Ethan what's your
address I said all right here we go I'm
gonna smell this girl's farts just you
know there we go I gave her the address
a couple weeks pass and sure enough here
we go we get the boss you checked in
with me yesterday she said hey I just
want to make sure you got the box
because you know customs may have thrown
it out they did not throw it out they
give it here now first of all let's look
at this box I don't know what's in this
dan has examined it and but I have not
seen it so first of all she sends in a
box with a kitty paw that she collude
the paper on so she's put effort this
has care and affection
here it says Belle Delphine mystery box
she glued it on this is paper handmade
handmade so she's put working into this
and she's got like a postcard here of
her with an egg once again we spoke
about we don't know what's the egg for
but I guess that's between her and the
egg so let's open it up finally so when
you open it up she wrote a personal
message here hello h3h3 I hope you got
my little box and no it's not my dirty
socks it's a little weird
I must admit but I sent you a bottle of
my own oh it's a poem oh she wrote a
little haiku for us dot dot dot I asked
for a fart butt fart doesn't rhyme with
admit
lots of love Belle Delphine so here she
got and she thought of everything we've
got the memory stick but she also sent a
Mac connector in case we wear a Mac
Genius this is incredible
so these have already been pre-loaded on
the computer right then yeah there's a
so deal that I just watch the video so
here's the package it's covered in a
pink ribbon and there's a sticker that
says Belle Delphine maybe we should open
it first and then watch the video do you
recommend that dan yeah open it first
and then the video will elucidate it
further okay so here we go I mean this
is a super exciting I mean seriously
tied really nice a pink ribbon I'm gonna
take it off very beautiful very nice
okay I'm removing the sticker which is
sealed for authenticity no one has ever
broken into this we need some drum rolls
or something yeah well okay I see we're
gonna drumroll go it's a lot of specs in
here oh my goodness what oh my goodness
that's a lot of liquid took a lot of
liquid it's a lot of little milky so
what I've gotten here is a lot of liquid
and it's very murky cloudy liquid it
looks like it's about an ounce I know
what else of liquid looks like now cuz
I've been feeding Theodore right I will
not be feeding this to Theodore however
it's a little white why is it so milky
there's lots of specks around the bottle
too but there is a seal you see how
there's a void of broken seal
she put a void it broken seal so you'll
know if it's been opened oh and there's
a really nice handwritten card here Wow
okay
Wow Wow
okay let's make sure I'm not missing
anything yeah I'm gonna read this to you
there's a lot on here whoa can you see
that we could see how much was on it
yeah okay I mean I didn't open that box
because I was saving for this so this
has not been prevented this is a cheat
sheet
what's a cheat see I don't know I think
I'm being trolled because the first line
is I [ __ ] hate Stuart Little
I know what you're thinking this is some
kind of funny joke but no Stuart littles
a piece of [ __ ] a damn rat got picked
over actual children had an orphanage
and he's supposed to be a hero are you
familiar with the Stuart Little or can
you give me a synopsis on Stuart little
just so we can have the full let's go
for this I believe it was a book before
it was a movie right it's a beloved
little piece of [ __ ] he's a damn rat
that got picked over actual children at
an orphanage and he's supposed to be a
hero
well I'm assuming the plot from that and
I can't even tell you how many damn
times I've seen a great parking space
only to turn the corner and realize
Stuart Little
has already parked there in a stupid
little [ __ ] convertible
he took my wife and the kids and my
house and my job I swear to [ __ ] god
I'm gonna kill myself and take that
goddamn road into hell with me is this a
copypasta that's what I was the Google
has ruined my family last summer I
approached the miserable Mouse in the
street and asked him for his autograph
because my son is a huge fan the [ __ ]
rat gave me the autograph and told me to
burn in hell
later when I gave my son the autograph
he started crying and said he hated me
turns out the mouse [ __ ] didn't write
his autograph no he wrote you're a piece
of [ __ ] and I [ __ ] your mom I'm now
divorced and planning a huge
class-action lawsuit against the white
devil that ruined my life your time is
almost over Stuart
all the people you've wronged will rise
against you goodbye
yeah it's a it's copypasta yeah okay she
managed to fill the car in I wonder if
she planned it out because it fits
perfectly well we'll have to cherish
that certainly I loved the egg what's
her thing with the egg what's the
explanation there well hopefully the
video shed some light on this because
that did not it's not a fart why is
there so much liquid it looks like soapy
water if I'm being honest I'll watch the
video do you think it's bath water no no
bath water should look like that
well we have a video so let's just stop
[ __ ] around now this is safe for work
right then you vetted it I have vetted
adjust okay here we go I mean this is a
video this is it you ready EULA yes
what so there's no idea no I don't
believe it
wait it's muted so she's just drooling
into a cup
lots of drool and yes a hey go face oh
my god oh there's a little bit of
giggling going on oh you can hear I hear
her doing a little Shh oh my god there's
no way did she really drool that much
hold on let me go back cuz I feel like
how do we get that much drool oh my god
remember when we did the 23andme it took
us forever to fill that that's true spit
thing dude I feel like this I would have
to pay a lot of money for this anyway
people would kill for this holy [ __ ]
that's all spit yo this is for I feel
like this is valuable so she's laughing
and smiling just until now and drooling
and spitting in this jar yo this is oh
my god okay this is old this is a lot
you touched that part oh my god she's
licking up the side of the jar holy crap
did she she back into the jar love this
oh my god and she's spitting it back Oh
freaking hell so much me well she
clearly was at this for a while so she
put it back in her mouth and drooled it
back out and now she's put the top on
and twirling it up putting all over her
face
kissing it okay that was Wow my god
there you go wow that was pretty erotic
wasn't it so who back there is fully
chubbed right now Zach I know you're
fully chub right now bro I'm very
intrigued right now
holy [ __ ] my job but it's so liquidy but
I guess after sitting for a while there
is one more item in that box
what yeah oh the half right so then they
also included Ione Bell Delphine spit
so they made a custom hat unless she
does this here pact I can proudly wear
this hat Wow that says I own Belle
Delphine spit no I feel like the street
value on this video and the spit has got
to be like at least God Tyr 2500 what do
we do it didn't sack are you gonna take
a sip of this
I won't sip it but I'll take it I'll
take away from it
maybe with a smile yeah so come in here
Zach yeah come in here and sit next to
me but you're gonna open this hill just
for a sniff yeah that's true I don't
want to because it's very collectible
I'm gonna sleek we can clone her someday
with this I should send us into to
23andme and see if analyze the DNA but I
guess like 50 percent see now I'm um I'm
a little nauseous wait but like I don't
know if she like has something you want
me to drink it like no I don't want you
to drink it okay no I'm glad I'm glad
you're up for it though that's what
matters yeah I guess spit over the
course of like a week would get diluted
like this and I'll get all that's
probably like her skin and flakes and
[ __ ] let's be real it's probably mold
growing in their little culture I guess
it's possible yeah there's a lot of
bacteria in the mouth is there like an
odor coming from it let's see I don't
want to I don't want to break the seal
it's void this is a collectible I know
when I go broke and that
and forgotten this shit's going on eBay
well hold on a second should I break the
seal I vote for no I think that ruins
well what am I gonna do smell it right
yeah that's not that you what that yeah
it's not know but smelling it is not
that exciting let's engage let's engage
further let's it that's exact come here
and smell this okay would you jerk off
with this would I jerk off with it yeah
I know probably not probably probably
saying there's a chance
well you know when you're in that state
of mind you'll do anything all right
sure of course all right I'm coming in
CA I feel bad breaking the seal though
or she even get these voids cuz you're
so cool I'm sorry Belle I have to we
have to examine the contents further
yeah that was that was I gotta say man
she went all out I'm sure she just
picked up a couple of patreon right now
it's too late we have to examine this
photo she went through all the effort so
it's the least we could did you opened
it
so yeah oh there's like a vacuum seal
what it's here listen listen I got
really there's a wicked smell coming off
that bro wait are we ready it's not
showing it's a spelling salt at least
would that be they're not seeing him yet
okay but at least um when I opened it
and there was a little pressure well you
know what happened there's probably
probably is bacteria in there so there's
a little air pressure when I opened it
it spit out what the bacteria was like
good enough guy used for yeah
sourdough right exactly that's right it
wasn't gnarly so there's like can you
hear is that okay well okay so hold off
on that okay yeah
but yeah this this is gnarly man I am so
I'm so blown away it's just not what I
expected at all
and we've got I mean damn what do you
think about this Gila I'm a fan of her I
feel like she's got great personality
from what I can tell and she's an
entrepreneur she's most definitely an
entrepreneur but I'm not I haven't
looked too much into the patreon page
because it's uh well it's just there's
not much to look in I do think she needs
to add your dad's name as a tier on here
though on her patreon people are gonna
want that I guess they can get it at the
gud tier yeah she should sponsor it i
love how she goes in through so much
details yes she went all out man just
and the fact that it's a poem with
rhymes so now we know yeah but I sent
you one so now we can complete the poem
I see I hope you got my little box and
no it's not my dirty socks it's a little
weird I must admit but I sent you a
bottle of my own spit very good man
that's crazy oh yeah yay how do you
become like this do you just grow up
watching anime and that's what you're
into I would assume because there I've
gotten into anime as an adult it's got a
picture with an egg what does it mean I
think it's a probably an inside joke
probably but as an adult I started
watching anime and there's so much like
crazy sexuality in it like I've been
watching a neon genesis evangelion on
Netflix and it's about a 14 year old and
every shot like in every episode is his
friend who's a 14 year old girl like
it's super sexual positions almost naked
and then his other roommate is like a
grown up girl who's always naked and you
have shots like from Becca
under vagina shot is what I call an
anime so I think if you grew up watching
this which I did in you would just be
like like my first time I saw a girl
naked was I was probably what like in a
victorious CR the first time I got
charged up was like a Victoria's Secret
catalog you know and so for kids who
grew up watching anime they probably
just got in all this those that make
sense to me
somehow I the first thing I saw was
Dragon Ball Z which is not like that not
sexy
and then Naruto which is also no yeah
not sexy so I'm and then I damn you
could have been okay why girl you could
if you would have watched the right
anime you'd be spending a jar right now
or your pastry on all right Zack hit us
with the drumroll actually don't I want
every sound okay yeah
[Music]
god this is happening no no no let it
breathe because you want it you want to
get your nose in there all right
good like booze really yeah this was
like alcohol it's been yeah
oh I smell it here it smells like beer
yes like booze because I do thinks
they're back there yeah I was drinking
alcohol no no you think he's just like
frankbooth bet her bacteria would
ferment but it's got to be her spit
right I mean there's no way she did a
you know what it smells like it smells
like Manischewitz hey he was going in it
smells like when we were trying to make
sourdough whoa it smells like a really
pungent wine yeah
are we being trolled this is definitely
your spit right I mean there was the
video proof and ways in which you have
they think it's really I think the
chunks in here is like the bacteria and
possibly the yeast
I'd like to know Bella fuel if we can
have an ongoing dialogue if you were
eating or drinking something
it took place Wow that smell is
incredible now you know those smelling
so are you gonna taste it no I don't
want you to either I don't think it's
safe no and not because she has STDs but
because that [ __ ] smell it's like it
actually something crazy
well we kept it for long enough maybe an
alien will start Italy just keep this
and watch it like no no no no I wanted
to activate we need to set a corner here
and call it area 52 well let's put it on
the TV so we can always see an area 52
you hear that dan set up a in area 52
rest up okay that's gnarly
dude that Wow I love eyes like a serial
number on it too and everything yeah
it's a super what wait what's it is it
number one no it's just some like
[ __ ] you get on the stick mm-hmm Wow
well it's not quite a fart but yeah it's
something it's kind of better yeah more
dynamic there's something growing in
there no right yeah it was a fart when
he opened it did I'm blown away like
dude are you freaking kidding me
oh my god
all right I better closes for again but
nuts in his panic in keep it together in
don't nut in your pants
well okay Zach thank you thank you thank
you for getting thinking now I
appreciate that
that was a mate I'm in truly we couldn't
have asked for a better package no so a
huge shout out to Bell and by the way
her Instagram was shut down which is an
abomination I am appalled she's part of
the h3 army and we must protect her I
have contacted Instagram I'm gonna I'm
gonna contact them mm-hmm and I'm gonna
I'm gonna do my best for her I mean
that's outrageous
this okay let's put this here this is
area 52 and let's just see what happens
inside feature disc remember the
Simpsons were Lisa grew like a little
civilization inside of a big reader it
kind of ruins like that
something's bound to happen in there
right I mean dude that smell was wild
yep googling around right now her count
is still banned as of right now and and
yeah it does seem to have been like a
concerted I guess report bomb whatever
you call it why would they do that a lot
of people hate her I mean in this
article it is seeing all these tweets of
people like this is the biggest win of
2019 so far he's stupid [ __ ] the
there's just angry men Belle Delphine
has been banned from Instagram this is
the greatest day of my life there's
really no angry meant that a girl can
make a living showing her tits I can't
believe she actually does so much more
than that these you know what why are
you out to ruin her as far as I could
tell she's earning a living the most
honest way possible she's super creative
I really don't understand that the
there's people that did consciously
dislike her while the h3 army rides for
bail I know that's I can't say the same
about thing about her mmm-hmm except
that her spit smells like fermented beer
which is in her fault well how do you
move on from that you just end it here
we have a lot more to go but like I
think we can save it for Tuesday yeah
that's yeah that's a good finale we've
been going a little over an hour and a
half it looks like we're just about an
hour now I'm such a I'm a huge fan dude
oh you know what we should do
what if I I kinda have a good idea and
you guys to you I this is gonna happen
so you can't stop me okay no the rubber
ducky
I don't know if we should introduce new
germs you know it's it's it's 100% her
that's true
right right right all right well okay
I'll get me a done game I'm gonna be so
fine to put the ducky in there all right
enough of this and I'll get you a copy
so you can take it home and Terk off
with it later time oh thanks
all right that's all we got
we'll be back on Tuesday and Friday
because we ride or die this is the h3
army our war there's no end to our war
it's forever war this war goes on
forever and I am your leader you must
follow me into battle because you know
they're out there we got to stop them
we all need to find area 52 because
that's the real that's where they keep
the real the real they moved it all the
area 52 what you mean yeah yeah okay one
is dead backup 50 ones like Windows you
know 95 area 52 is that new [ __ ] that
Windows XP yeah that new [ __ ] boy I
don't think XP is an issue
what's the new [ __ ] load of 10 baby
Windows ex
crazy what an episode huh I mean look at
us look at us there's nothing we can't
do we just opened a jar of spit that
smelled like beer sent to us from
England Oh Bell I wanted to say we will
fly you out and put you in a hotel what
- come on the pot we will cover all your
expenses let's do it
you're in the UK I want you as a guest
that was his idea it was I would like to
yeah yeah so let's go that's it well be
back on Tuesday guys have a fantastic
weekend we wish you all the best love
you we appreciate you and I really hope
this episode makes it because we've been
smelling bath salts and watching spit
porn
hopefully we miss you guys and if not we
really did try our best good bye thank
you bye
[Music]